thanks to audible for sponsoring this
episode hey crazies I've made a bold
statement a few times in this channel
but how true is that
his energy always conserved it's a big
fat no isn't it more like a little itty
bitty now before we get into that though
let's get a definition out of the way
conservation is a word you've probably
heard in reference to the environment
it means we're trying to keep the
environment the way it is we don't want
it to change you know so humans can keep
living and all that good stuff it can
serve quantity is just like that it's a
number that stays the same over time
energy fits that description most of the
time you could imagine this squirrel has
a force of gravity on it
which causes an acceleration by Newton's
second law or you could imagine the
squirrel starts with a certain amount of
energy as the squirrel Falls potential
energy is transformed into kinetic
energy right before impact it's all
kinetic energy the same amount that we
had at the beginning in potential energy
the total amount never changes you just
have to keep track of where it goes
there are a lot of different types of
energy elastic rotational vibrational it
can even be divided microscopically
among an object's particles so let's
keep going with that poor squirrel and
see what happens upon impact the energy
is transformed into thermal energy the
squirrel and the ground are warmer than
they were before at least a little bit
it's not just limited to falling
squirrels either it works for
projectiles the energy transforms but
the total never changes
got a ball rolling down a ramp still
works simple pendulum still works double
pendulum still works nuclear explosion
still works no that escalated quickly
anyway the point is this there's a
principle of conservation of energy that
says energy can neither be created nor
destroyed it can only be transformed or
transfer
except it's kind of a lie sometimes yes
but but the situation has to be pretty
extreme like cosmic timescale kind of
extreme it's true most of the time but
every rule has its limits even the good
ones this is where neuters theorem comes
in it states that all conserved
quantities whether that's energy or
momentum or charge or whatever are the
result of some invariance or symmetry in
the universe if you can vary one
condition like where or when an event
takes place and that event plays out
exactly the same way there must be a
conserved quantity some measurement that
stays the same over time so let's see if
we can find an invariance for that
falling squirrel he speeds up as he
falls at a very particular rate but if
he fell at night it wouldn't look any
different the same goes for yesterday or
a hundred years from now
the squirrels fall looks the same that's
what we call time translation invariance
we can do an experiment whenever we'd
like and we should get the same results
seems reasonable right but if we think
of a large enough timescales it's not
always true on the cosmic timeline some
events that happened in the distant past
would turn out differently if they
happen now or a billion years from now
to understand why we need to know where
neuters theorem comes from Lagrangian
mechanics we just did a video on it if
you want more details or you're
unfamiliar but here's a summary it's
based on something we call the principle
of stationary action an action is kind
of a measure of efficiency or effort
basically the universe is lazy generally
we use the action principle to derive
more useful equations like Snell's law
or the Euler Lagrange equations or
Einsteins field equations but sometimes
we need to go back to the action
principle to kind of get our bearings so
what's the action look like on the
cosmic scale
great question clone great question
question come on whatever first adding
over just time isn't gonna cut it we
need to add overall time and space
because they're really just one thing
that brings us to the Lagrangian we'll
want it to account for everything there
should be a term for the matter in the
universe a term for the electromagnetic
field which includes all the light in
the universe and a term for space-time
itself it's that last term that ruins
everything
remember conservation of energy requires
time translation invariance if space
expands over time we don't have that
kind of invariance now that expansion is
very gradual so over small timescales
energy is approximately conserved like
so close to being conserved you might as
well just say it is but I can give you
two examples where it isn't the Cosmic
Microwave Background
and dark energy the Cosmic Microwave
Background or CMB is light that's been
around since the universe was young it
was emitted when the universe was only a
few hundred thousand years old and it's
been traveling ever since back then the
CMB was so energetic that it peaked in
visible light the entire observable
universe used to look like this but that
light has been traveling a long time
through expanding space it's been red
shifted so much that it's not visible
anymore it's all the way down here in
the microwave range that's lower energy
light the CMB has lost energy over time
it hasn't goin anywhere else it's just
gone and the opposite happens with dark
energy the other name for dark energy is
the cosmological constant it's an energy
density energy per unit volume if space
expands over time that means space has
more volume over time which means there
has to be more dark energy to keep the
density constant as the volume goes up
the energy must also go up but doesn't
the loss in energy and the CMB make up
for that
no there isn't nearly enough CMB for
that to work out dark energy is
increasing at a much higher rate than
the CMB loses energy we live in a dark
energy dominated era of the universe
there is a net energy gain
of course this is a total bummer so
people have tried to redefine energy to
fix it here's a notable example but it's
controversial at best so is energy
always conserved no not always
in normal everyday circumstances it's so
close to being conserved you might as
well say it is it gives you an extremely
useful tool for making predictions but
on cosmic timescales the expansion of
space prevents that tool from being a
universal law so what do you think
should we redefine energy to make it
conserved or just let it go please share
your thoughts in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video a special
thanks goes out to holy crap we have a
warden of the asylum ydt thank you so
much for your support this is huge
Wow anyway don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy thanks to audible for
sponsoring the science asylum listen up
Amazon Prime members for a limited time
you can start an audible membership and
save 66% on your first three months a
total of $30 off that's like getting
three months for the price of one you'll
pay just four ninety-five a month for
the first three months and after that
it's only fourteen ninety-five a month
this offer is valid from July 1st to
July 31st audible is great on the go
whether you're at the beach hiking or
road tripping listen anytime anywhere
every month you get one free audiobook
and two free audible originals from an
ever-changing list I'd recommend
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy by
Douglas Adams it's got a nice level of
absurdity and Stephen Fry was a perfect
choice to narrate if you're interested
visit audible.com slash the science
asylum or text the science asylum to
five hundred five hundred to get started
today to everyone wondering why I didn't
go into more detail in the last video I
don't work out map steps ok that's not
what I do but if you're into that
there's a chapter in my ebook you might
like I even run through the derivation
of Einstein's field equations in
excruciating detail linked in the
doobly-doo anyway thanks for watching